the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu ok ok so today we're going
to continue on with some of the design
patterns they started talking about last
week so to recap there are really four
common steps to taking a program and
then paralyzing it often you're starting
off with a program that's designed or
written in sequential manner and what
you want to do is find tasks in the
program and these are sort of
independent work pieces that you're
going to be able to decompose from your
sequential code you're going to group
tasks together into threads or processes
and then you'll essentially map each one
of these threads or processes down to
the actual hardware and that will get
you eventually when news programs run
the concurrency and the performance
speed ups that you want so it's an
endurance of finding the task of finding
the concurrency you start off with an
application you come up with its block
level diagram and from that you sort of
try to understand where the where the
time is spent in the computation and
what are some typical patterns for how
the computations carried out so we
talked about tas decomposition or sort
of it's an independent task or task that
might be different that the application
is carrying out so in the MPEG encoder
we looked at decoding the motion vectors
for temporal compression versus spatial
compression it does sort of
substantially different work we talked
about data decomposition so if you're
doing a process so if you have some work
that's really consuming a large chunk of
data and you realize that it's applying
the same kind of work to each of those
data pieces then you can partition your
data into smaller subsets and apply the
same kind of apply the same function
over and over again
okay so in the motion compensation phase
that's one example where you can
replicate the function and split up the
data stream in different ways and have
these tasks proceed in parallel so
that's data decomposition and then we
talked a little bit about sort of making
a case for a pipeline decomposition so
you have a data assembly line or
producer-consumer chains and you
essentially want to recognize those in
your computation and make it so that you
can exploit them eventually when you're
doing your mapping down to actual
hardware but what does it mean for two
tasks actually be concurrent and how do
you know that you can safely actually
run two tests in parallel so there's
something I crudely went over last time
so to make it more more concrete
highlighting Bernstein's condition which
says that given two tasks if the input
set to one task is different from or is
does not intersect with the input set to
do with the output set of another and
vice versa and neither task sort of
upset updates the same data structures
in memory then there's really no
dependency issues between them you can
run them safely in parallel so TAS t1
and t2 if all the data that's consumed
by t1 so all data elements that are read
by t1 are different from the ones that
are read by t2 then you have you know if
t2 is running in parallel there's really
no no problem with t1 because it's
updating an orthogonal data set
similarly 42 and he want any outputs are
different so as an example let's say you
have two tasks and t1 you're doing some
basic statements and then these could be
essentially more coarse grained it could
be a lot of more computation in here
just simplified it for the for the
illustration so you have task k equals x
plus y and task to does b equals x plus
z so if we look at the read set 41 these
are all the variables or data structures
or addresses that are read by the first
half so that's x and y here and all the
data it's trinh or produced by teach at
t1 so here we're just producing one data
value and that's going into ok
janae similarly we can come up with the
reset and write set 42 and so that's
shown on here so we have TAS t2 has X
plus C in a street set and it produces
one data value B if we take the
intersection of the read and write sets
for the different tests and they're
empty I read something really different
than what's producing this task vice
versa and they write to two completely
different memory locations so I can
essentially paralyzed these run these
two tasks in parallel so you can extend
this in this analysis and compilers can
actually use this condition to determine
12 task and we paralyze if you're doing
automatic paralyzation and you'll
probably hear more about these later on
and so what I focus on last time where
the finding concurrency patterns and I
had identifies her for design spaces
based on the work that's done at its
outline in the book by Max and Sanders
in massengill and so starting with two
large sort of concepts the first helps
you just figure out how are you going to
actually express your algorithm so first
you find your concurrency and then you
are organized in some way and so we're
going to talk about that in more detail
and then once you've organized your
tasks in some way that actually
expresses your overall computation you
need some software construction
utilities or data structures or
mechanisms for actually orchestrating
computation for which they've also
abstracted at some common patterns and
so I'll briefly talk about these as well
and so in the algorithm expression side
these are essentially conceptualization
steps it helps you abstract out your
problem and you may in fact think about
your algorithm expression in different
ways to expose different kinds of
concurrency or to be able to explore
different ways of mapping the
concurrency to hardware and so for
construction is more about actual
engineering and implementation so here
you're actually thinking about what are
the data structures look like what is
the communication patterns I'm going to
look like i'm going to use things like
MPI or OpenMP what does that help me
with in terms of
doing my implementation so given
collection of concurrent test so you've
done your first step in your Ford design
patterns yeah what is your next step and
that's really mapping those tasks that
you've identified down to some sort of
execution units so threads are very
common this is essentially what we've
been using on cell we take our
computation we wrap it into SPE threads
and then we can execute those at runtime
so some things to keep in mind although
you shouldn't over constrain yourself in
terms of these considerations what is
the magnitude of your parallelism that
you're going to get you know do you want
hundreds or thousands of threads or do
you want something on order of tens and
this because this is because you don't
want overwhelm you overall the intended
system that you're going to run on so we
talked about yesterday on cell processor
if you're creating a lot more than six
threads then you can create problems or
you essentially don't get extra
parallelism because each thread is
running to completion on each SPE and
context which overhead extremely high so
you don't want to spend too much
engineering costs to come up with an
algorithm implementation that's
massively scalable to hundreds or
thousands of threads one you can't
actually exploit it but that doesn't
mean that you should over constrain your
implementation to where if now I want to
take your code and run on a different
machine I essentially have to redesign
re-engineer the complete process so you
want to avoid tendencies to over
constrain implementation and you want to
leave your code in a way that's
malleable so you can easily make changes
to sort of factoring new platforms that
you want to run on or new machine
architecture features that you might
want to exploit so there are four three
major organization principles I'm going
to talk about and none of these should
be sort of foreign to you at this point
because we've talked about them in
different ways are they threw in
recitations or in previous lectures and
it's really what is it that determines
sort of the algorithm structure based on
set of tasks that you're actually
carrying out in your computation and so
there's the principle that says organize
things by tasks I'm going to talk
through that and then there's principal
let's as well organize things by how
you're doing a data decomposition so
this case how are you actually
distributing the data over how the data
is laid out in memory or how you're
partitioning the data to actually
computer on it dictates how you should
actually organize your actual
computation and then there's organized
by flow of data and this is something
you'll hear hear about more in the next
lecture what we're talking about
streaming but in this in this pattern if
yours if there are specific sort of
computations that take advantage of how
high bandwidth flow of data between
computations you might want to exploit
that fer concurrency and we'll talk
about that as well ok show sort of a
design diagram for how can you actually
go through use process so you can ask
yourself a set of questions if I want to
organize things by task then they're
essentially to two main clusters or two
main computation to make patterns if the
code is recursive then you essentially
want to apply divine and conquer pattern
or divide and pot via and conquer
organization if it's not recursive then
you essentially want to do task
parallelism so in Cass parallelism these
you know I've listed two examples here
but really any of these things we've
talked about in past fit right
computation the ray tracing so here
you're shooting raised through seem to
try to determine sort of how to render
it and really each ray is a separate and
independent computation step in
molecular dynamics you're trying to
determine the non-bonded force
calculations there are some dependencies
but really you can do each calculation
for for one molecule or for one atom
independent of any other and then
there's sort of the global dependence of
having to update or communicate across
all those molecules to sort of reflect
new physicians in the system so the
common factors here are your tasks are
associated with in with iterations of a
loop and you can distribute the you know
each process each processor can do a
different iteration of the loop and
often you know sort of what the tasks
are before you actually start your
computation although in some cases like
in ray tracing you might generate more
and more threads as you go along or more
and more computation because as the rate
is shooting off your
calculating new things that are new
flexions and that creates those sort of
extra work but largely you have these
independent tasks that you can capsulate
in threads and you run them and this is
sort of a might appear subtle but there
are algorithm classes we're not all
tasks essentially need to complete for
you to arrive at a solution you know
some cases you might convert your
acceptable solution and you don't
actually need to go through an exercise
all the egg all the computation that's
outstanding for you to say the program
is done so there'll be a tricky issue
i'll revisit this just briefly later on
is how do you determine if your program
is actually terminated or has completed
and divide and conquer this is really
for recursive programs you know you can
think of well known sorting out with a
merge sort that classically fits into
this kind of picture where you have some
really large array of data you want to
sort you keep subdividing into smaller
and smaller chunks until you can do
local reordering and then you started
emerging things together so this gives
you sort of a way to take a problem
divided into subproblems and then you
can split the data at some point then
you join it back together you merge it
MIT things like fork and merge or fork
and join use instead of splitting joint
I've used this terminology sort of melds
well with some of the concepts we use in
streaming that you'll see in the next
lecture and so in these kind of programs
it's not always the case that each
subproblem will have essentially the
same amount of work to do you might need
more a more dynamic load balancing
because each subproblem how you
distribute the data might lead you to do
more work in one problem than in the
other so as opposed to some of the other
mechanisms where static load balancing
will work really well in this in to
remind you static load balancing
essentially says you have some work you
assign it to each of the processors and
you're going to be relatively happy with
how the each processors sort of
utilization is going to be over time
nobody's going to be too overwhelmed
with the amount of work they have to do
in this case you might end up with
needing some things for dynamic load
balancing that says I'm unhappy with the
work performance
or utilization some processors are more
idle than the others so you might want
to essentially redistribute things so
we'll talk about you know how does this
concept of a divide and conquer
paralyzation pattern work into the
actual implementation you know how do I
actually implement a divide and conquer
organization the next organization is
organized by data so here you have some
computation not your lights flickering
that's good
okay so in any organized by data you
want to see you essentially want to
apply this if you have a lot of
computation that's using shared global
data structure or that's going to update
a central data structure so in molecular
dynamics for example you have a huge
array that that records the position of
each amount of each of the molecules and
while you can do the force calculations
independently eventually everybody or
all the parallel tasks have to
communicate with the central data
structure and say here are the new
locations for all the molecules and so
that has to go into central repository
and there are different kinds of sort of
decompositions within this organization
if your data structure is recursive so a
linked list or a tree or a graph then
you can apply to recursive data pattern
if it's not if it's linear like an array
or a vector then you apply geometric
decomposition and you've essentially
seen geometric decomposition these were
some of the labs that you've already
done and so the example from yesterday's
recitation you're doing an N body
simulation in terms of who's gravitating
towards who you're calculating the
forces between pairs of objects and
depending on the force that each object
feels you calculate a new accelerate a
new motion vector and you use that to
update the position of each body in your
say galaxy that you're stimulating and
so what we talked about yesterday was
given an array of positions each
processor gets a sub chunk of that
position array and it knows how to
calculate sort of locally based on that
and then you might also communicate
local chunks to do more scalable
computations in recursive data structure
are a little bit more tricky so at face
value might think that there's really no
kind of parallelism you can get out of a
recursive data structure so if you're
iterating over a list and you want to
get to some well you know I just need to
go through the list can I really
paralyzed that there are however
opportunities where you can reshape
operations or reshape the computation in
a way
exposes concurrency and often what this
comes down to is you're going to do more
work but it's okay because you're going
to finish faster so this kind of work
and currently trade-off I'm going to
illustrate with an example so in in this
application we have some graph and for
each node in the graph we want to know
what is its true so this works well when
you have a forest we're not all the
graphs are connected and given a node
you want to know who's the root of this
graph so we can do is essentially have
more concurrency by changing the way we
actually think about the algorithm so
rather than starting with each node and
then in a directed graph following its
successor so this is essentially order n
because for each node we have to follow
and links we can think about it slightly
differently so what if rather than
finding a successor and then finding
that successor successor at each
computational step we start with a node
and we say who is your successor
successor so we can converge in this
example in three steps so from five to
six we can say who's who is this
successor so who's was a successor
successor of five and that would be 2
and similarly you can do that for seven
and so on and so you keep asking the
question so you can distribute all these
data structures repeatedly ask these
questions out of all these end nodes and
it leads you to an order log n solution
versus an order end solution but what
have I done in each step well I've
actually created myself and much at I
would sort of increase the amount of
work that I'm doing by order n right
there right yes because I've essentially
for each for each node doing n queries
you know who's your successor successor
whereas in sequential case you know I
just need to do it once for each node
and that works really well so most
strategy is based on this pattern of
actually decomposing your computation
according to recurse pattern leaves you
two doing much much more work or some
constant in the end some increase in the
amount of work but you get this back in
because you can
crees your execution and so this is a
good trade-off that you might want to
consider yeah this type oh yeah so
organized by flow or organized by flow
of data and this is essentially the
pipeline model and we talked about this
again in some of the recitations in
terms of SPE to SPE communication or do
you want to organize based on event
based mechanism so what these really
come down to is well how regular is the
flow of data in your application if you
have regular let's say one-way flow
through stable computation path so I've
set up my sort of algorithm structure
data is flowing through it at regular
rate the computation graph isn't
changing very much then I can
essentially pipeline things really well
and this could be a linear chain of
computation or they could be sort of
nonlinear it could be branches excuse me
in the graph and I can use that in a way
to exploit pipeline parallelism if I
don't have sort of dis- structure they
could be events that are created at
runtime so for example you know you're a
car wash tenant and the new car comes in
so you have to find a garage for it to
assign to it and then trigger on the car
wash machine so they're dynamic threads
that are created based on sensory input
that comes in then you might want to use
an event space coordination yeah
irregular computation computation might
vary based on the data that comes into
your system and you might have
unpredictable unpredictable data flow so
in the pipeline model the things to
consider is the pipeline throughput
versus the pipeline latency so the
amount of concurrency in a pipeline is
really limited by the number of stages
this is nothing new you've seen this for
example in super scale of pipelines and
just as in this case as in the case of
an architecture pipeline the amount of
time it takes you to fill the pipeline
and the amount of time takes your drain
pipe line can essentially limit your
parallelism so you want those to be
really small compared to the actual
computation that you
been in your pipeline and the
performance metric is usually the
throughput how much data can you pump
through your pipeline per per unit time
so in video encoding you know it's the
frames per second that you can produce
and pipeline latency though is important
especially in real time application
where you need a result every 10
milliseconds you know your pacemaker for
example has to produce a beep or a
signal to your heart that specific rates
so need to consider what is your
pipeline throughput versus your pipeline
lane seeing that can actually determine
how many stages you might want to
actually decomposed or organize your
application in and in the event based
coordination these are interactions of
tasks over unpredictable intervals and
your you're more prone to sort of
deadlocks in these applications because
you might have cyclic dependencies where
one event can't proceed until it gets
data from another event but it can't
proceed until it gets data from another
event and you can create sort of these
complex interactions that often lead to
deadlock so you have to sort of be very
careful in structuring things together
so you don't end up with visa feedback
loops that block computation progress so
given sort of these three organizational
structures that say you know I can
organize my computation by cass or by
the flow of data or by sort of the
pipeline nature of the computation what
are the supporting structures how to
actually implement these and so there
are many different sporting structures
I've identified sort of four that occur
most often in literature and books and
common terminology that's used and so
those RS PMD loop parallelism the mast
masterwork a pattern and the fork joint
pattern in the SB md pattern you're
talking about a single program multiple
data concept so here you just have one
program you write it once and then you
assign it to each of your processors to
run so it's the same program it just
runs on different machines now each
program or each instance of the code can
have different control floated it takes
so just because they're running the same
program doesn't mean the computation
happening in lockstep that would be a
sort of a simdi or vector like
confrontation in this model you can
actually take independent control float
it could be different behavior in each
instance of the code but you're running
the same code everywhere so this is
slightly different for example from what
you've seen on cell where you have a
cell at the PPE thread that creates SPE
threads sometimes the SPE threads are
the same but it's not always the case
that the PPE thread and the SPE threads
are the same so in the SPM d model there
really five steps that you do you
initialize sort of your computation in
the world of sort of code instances that
you're going to run and for each one you
obtain a unique identifier and this
usually helps them being able to
determine who needs to communicate with
who or ordering dependencies and you run
the same program on each processor and
what you need to do in this case is also
distribute that your data between each
of the different instances of your code
and once you you know each program is
running its computing on its data
eventually need to finalize in some way
and so that might mean doing a reduction
to communicate all data to one processor
to actually output the value and so we
saw an spm d example for the numerical
integration for calculating pi and if
you remember so we had this very simple
C loop and we showed the MPI
implementation of the sea loop and so it
in in this code what we're doing is
we're trying to determine different
intervals and for each interval will go
into calculate the value and then in the
MPI program we're essentially deciding
how big an interval each process should
run so it's the same program it runs on
every single machine or every single
processor and each processor determines
based on its ID how much actual which
interval of the actual integration to do
and so in this model we're distributing
work relatively evenly each processor is
doing a specific chunk that starts at
say some index I and if I have 10
processors I'm doing 100
steps then you're doing I I plus 10 I
plus 20 and so on but I can do a
different distribution so the first is a
block distribution I can do something
called a cyclic distribution so in the
cyclic distribution i distribute work
sort of in a round-robin fashion or some
other mechanism so here you know each
processor sorry I screw up in in the
block distribution I start sort of start
an interval I and I go sorry so each
processor gets one entire slice here so
I start here and I go through the
completion I start here go through the
completion in a cyclic distribution I
might do smaller slices of each one of
those intervals so I grade at the
components for the blade for the block
distribution and just show you that for
a contrast here there are some
challenges in the SS PMD model and that
is how do you actually split your data
correctly you have to distribute your
data in a way that you know increase
doesn't increase contention on your
memory system where each actual
processor that's assigned computation
has data locally to community to
actually operate on and you want to
achieve an even work distribution you
need a dynamic load balancing scheme or
can you use an alternative pattern if
that's not suitable so the second
pattern as opposed to spm V pattern is
loop parallelism pattern in this case
this is best suited when you actually
have a programming model or a program
that you can't really change the whole
lot or that you don't really want to
change the whole lot or you have a
programming model that allows you to
sort of identify loops that take up most
of the computation and then insert
annotations or some ways to
automatically paralyzed those loops so
we saw in the openmp example you have
some loop you can insert these pragmas
that say this loop is parallel and the
compiler endnote and the runtime system
can automatically partition this loop
into smaller chunks and then each
chunking can compute in power
and you might apply this scheme in
different ways depending on how well you
understand your code are you running on
a shared memory machine you can't afford
to do a whole lot of restructuring
communication costs might be really
expensive in the master worker pattern
this is really starting to get closer to
what we've done with the cell
recitations in the cell labs you have
some world of independent tasks and the
master is essentially running and
distributing each of these tasks to
different processors so in this case you
get several advantages that you can
leverage if each of your tasks are very
nature and they might finish a different
times or they're require different kinds
of resources you can use this model to
sort of view your machine as sort of a
non-symmetric processor not everybody is
the same and you can use this model
really well for that so you can
distribute these and then you can do
dynamic load balancing because as
processors as workers finish you can
ship them more and more data so it has
some particularly relevant properties
for for for heterogeneous computations
but it's also really good for when you
have a whole lot of parallelism in your
application so something called
embarrassingly parallel problems so ray
tracing molecular dynamics a lot of
scientific applications have these
massive levels of parallelism and you
can use this essentially work you based
mechanism that says I have all these
tasks and I'll just patch them to
workers and compute and as I pointed out
earlier you know when do you define your
entire computation to have completed
sometimes your computing a result until
you've reached some some some result and
often you're willing to accept a result
within some range of error and you might
have some more threads that are still in
flight do you terminate your computation
then or not what are some issues with
synchronization if you have so many
threads that are running together you
know does the communication between them
to say to send out these control
messages say
done start to overwhelm you in the fork
joint pattern this is really not
conceptually two different in my mind
from the work from the work from master
worker model and also very relevant to
what we've done with cell you have tasks
that the main difference it might be
that you have tasks are dynamically
created so in the embarrassingly
parallel case you actually know the
world of all your potential tasks that
you go in to run in parallel in the four
join model some new computation might
come up as a result of say an event
based mechanism so taz might be created
dynamically and then later terminated or
they might complete and so new ones come
up as a result join model just keep
poking as flip book shows up right might
not be completely match the number of
process available at six things and then
accepting work or just bc 84 work
whereas here s welcomes you to this
pokemon
so did the process that's creating all
these threads or that's doing all the
forking is often known as the parent and
the tasks that are generated our
children and eventually essentially the
pattern the parent can't continue or
can't resume until its children have
sort of completed or have reached the
joint point until those are really some
of the models that we've seen already in
a lot of cases in the recitations and
labs for how you run your computations
and some of you have already discovered
these and actually thinking about how
your project should be sort of paralyzed
for your actual cell cell demos so many
other things I'm just going to talk
about our communication patterns so two
lectures ago you saw for example that
you have point-to-point communication or
you have broadcast communication so in
point-to-point communication you have
two tasks that need to communicate and
they can send explicit messages to each
other these could be control messages
that say I'm done or I'm waiting for
data or they can be data messages it
actually ships you particular data
element that you might need and again
we've seen this with cell broadcast says
you know I have some result at everybody
needs and so I send that out to
everybody by some mechanism there is no
real broadcast mechanism on sell it
concept i'm going to talk about though
is the reduction mechanism which really
is the inverse of the broadcast so in
the broadcasts i have data element i
need to send to everybody else in the
reduction all of you have data that i
need or all of us have dated at each
somebody else needs so what we need to
do is collectively bring that data
together or group it together and
generate an end result so a simple
example of a reduction you have some
array of elements that you want to add
together and sort of the result of the
collective operation is the end some so
you have an array of four elements a 0 a
1 a 2 and a 3 and you can do a serial
reduction I can take a zero and add it
to a one and that gives me a result
and I can take a two and add to add that
to it and I can take a three and add
that to it and so at the end I've sort
of calculated some from a0 to a3 so this
is essentially the cereal reduction
applies when your operation is an
associative so the addition is
associative so in this case I can
actually do something more intelligent
i'm going to show you know and that i
think we talked about that last time i'm
going to show you some more examples and
often served end result follows a
broadcast it says here's the end result
who are all the people that needed a las
or broadcast that out so that everybody
has a result if your operation isn't
associative then you're essentially
limited to a serial process and so
that's not very good from performance in
a standpoint some of the tricks you can
apply for actually getting performance
out of your reduction is to go to a
tree-based reduction model so this might
be very obvious rather than doing a 0
and a 1 and then adding a 22 that result
I can do a 0 and a 1 together in
parallel I can do a2 and a3 and then I
can get those results and add them
together so rather than doing n steps i
can do log n steps so this is a
particularly attractive when only one
task needs the results so in the MPI
program when we're doing the integration
to calculate pi you know one processor
and used to print out that value of pi
but if you have a computation where more
than one process actually needs a result
of reduction there's actually a better
mechanism you can use that's sort of a
better alternative to the tree based
reduction followed by a broadcast so you
can do a recursive doubling reduction so
this is so at the end here every process
will have the result of the reduction
without having done the broadcast so we
can start off as with the tree based and
add of add off add up a zero and a one
together but what we do is for each
process that has a value or we sort of
do a local exchange so from here we
communicate the value to here and from
here we communicate the value to hear
and so now these two processors that had
the value independently now both have a
local
a 0 to a 1 and similarly we can sort of
make the similar symmetric computation
on the other side and now we can
communicate data from these two
processors here to come up with you and
yeah it was there unless it was in the
animation so you actually do that the
other way as well so that you have the
sum a 0 2 a 3 on all the different
processors sorry about the loss
animations okay so this is better than
the tree based approach with a broadcast
because you end up with local results of
your reduction and rather than doing
yeah the broadcast following the tree
based reduction would take send steps
you end up with an order n everybody has
a result in order n versus an order to n
process for for the tree based plus
broadcast a mere selling boss not in
general
it depends on sort of the architectural
mechanism that you have for for your
network if you actually do need to sort
of you know if you have a broadcast
mechanism that has a bus based
architecture where you can deposit local
value everybody can pull that value then
yeah it can be more efficient or in
optical networks you can broadcast the
data and everybody can just use it out
okay so summarizing all the different
patterns so here these are actual
mechanisms that you would use for how
you would implement the different
patterns so in the SP MD or write the
same program and loop parallelism you
have your program you might annotate
some pragmas they tell you how to
paralyze your computation and the master
worker model you might have sort of
master that's going to create threads
and you actually know the work you might
sort of have a very good idea of what is
the kind of work you're going to do in
each thread and the fork join model you
have more dynamism to might create
threads on the fly and you apply these
sort of based on appeal or what is more
suited in terms of implementation to
each of the different patterns for how
you actually organize your data so in
the task parallelism model this is where
you have a world of threads that you
know you're going to calculate or that
you're going to use for your computation
and really you can use largely any one
of these models so i use the ranking
system where four star is really good 1
stars sort of bad or no star means not
well suited his monsters sometimes
monster might get little beautiful pie
see
right so going to be a part of any
masters right although you could use the
cell master to do regular computation as
well but yes so in the divide and
conquer model you know might be
especially well-suited for a fork and
joined because you're creating all these
recursive sub problems they might be
heterogeneous in the nature of the
computation that you do you might have
more problems created dynamically for
join really works well for that and in
fact you know the subproblem structure
that i showed the graph of sort of
division and then merging works really
well with the four join model in the
recursive in a geometric decomposition
this is where this is essentially your
lab one exercise and things we went over
yesterday in recitation you're taking
data and you're partitioning over
multiple processors actually compute in
parallel so this could be SPM d
implementation or it could be a loop
parallelism implementation which we
didn't do less suitable master worker
and fork joint often because the
geometric decomposition applies some
distribution to the data which has
static properties that you can exploit
in various ways so you don't need to pay
the overhead of master worker or for
joint recursive data structures sort of
have very specific models that you can
run with largely master worker is a
decent implementation choice SPM D is
another and you're going to hear more
about sort of the pipeline mechanism in
the next talk so I'm not going to talk
about that very much event-based
coordination largely dynamic so for
joint works really well so yeah so that
looks like so the sort of these choices
or these stray dogs aren't really
orthogonal you can actually combine them
in different ways and in a lot of
applications what you might find is that
the the different patterns compose
hierarchically and you actually want
that in various ways
for various reasons so in the MPEG
example you know we had tasks here
within each task and identified some
pipeline stages you know here I have
some data parallelism so I can apply the
loop pattern here and what I want to do
is actually in my computation so express
these different mechanisms so I can
understand their different trade-offs
and for really large applications there
might be different patterns are well
suited for the actual computation and
I'm doing so I can combine things like
pipelining with task based mechanism or
data parallelism to actually get really
good performance speed ups and one of
the things that that might strike you is
well heck this is a whole lot of work
that I have to do to actually get my
code in the right way so that I can
actually take advantage of my parallel
architecture you know I have to
conceptually think about the question in
the right way I have to maybe
restructure my computation in different
ways to actually exploit parallelism
data distribution is really hard I have
to get that right synchronization issues
might be problem and how much buffering
do i need to do between different tasks
so the thing you hear about the next
talk is well what if these things really
fall out naturally from the way you
actually write the program and if that
actual if the way you actually write
your program matches really well with
the intuitive sort of natural
conceptualization of the problem and so
i'll leave bill to talk about that and
i'm gonna stop here any questions
yeah i talked about a fortune join when
you have a parent thread that spawns up
to teach all threads how do you keep so
you have for joint where and so you just
hope joy might not really use PP unless
you can you know you have some time and
you to some other tasks can come back so
like our purposes we shun and spa
appointment as these so yeah so most of
the threads that are spawned off are
done by the PPE so you have giza in fact
a good walk through anniversa tation
yesterday you have the PPE essentially
it sends messages to the SPS that says
create these threads and start running
them here's the data for them and then
these spreads run on the SP es and they
just do local computation and then they
send messages back to the PPE that says
we're done so that's essentially
implements a joint mechanism so a
master-slave way and then a speedy can
send a message and then deliver another
job into the into the pp who leaves the
master is pleased to you like this are
more confident it can be okay look put
this into your children and keeps any
messages and so so the master can can
can look at that an update that you so
you look it's not only master whose
quest for hope but but the slaves also
this piece can can send information back
so so you can think about things like
something like you added confidant that
way Yeah right there are a bike is six
SP is running and you first get
something sin then Andy chess pieces
sundae for divide it will take one task
around
and send other one to the master here
say their samples finish it affect me
here's my ID sent me the message when
it's done so you hold that end anyway so
you can you can assume we can do
something like that so it's almost ma a
master-slave but but this coordination
in there the trouble with normally for
joint is to create too many threads you
are like a friend helping things to run
I don't can you cut marks and this piece
now so so you can't even through that
because there's some physical limitation
you can't create up inside haven't
seemed somebody to be babe you 20,000
read your run another master slave think
yourself could you ty multiplex two
thousand friends on top of your SPS and
that's going to be locked your influence
both players yeah context switching on
SPE is very expensive so if you create
more territorial on the PlayStation 3's
you have six sb's available to you so if
you have a lot more than six threads
that you've created essentially each one
runs to completion and then you swap
that out and you bring in well that
terminates UD allocated from the SP and
you bring in a new thread if you
actually want to do more thread like
with dynamic load balancing on SPS it's
not well suited for that just because of
the PV is used must apart if you to run
most of the sequential code and then
when they're parallel thinks it will
send you can keep the Q and probably the
word commoditizing send stuff if SP and
feed that and even like so what you type
models can be anything there yeah and
yes p.m. tomorrow might not work with
well because you have this heterogeneity
in the actual hardware right so if I am
taking the same program running on the
SPE versus the PPE that code might not
be so I essentially have to specialize
the code and that that starts to deviate
away from the most of the more you
rightful say
we'll probably mask ever I think he'll
try to do something other than you
should think hard why you can do for
join but you know it's in the New
America because you don't have a
virtualization you for too much then I
will come to this kind of the fourth
yeah in that sense you can you talk too
much computer work you on the master can
for things you can you can go virtual
for and say the word to the mask and say
hey I folk something is the world the
key thing is do the simplest thing I
mean you guys have two weeks left and if
you try to anything complicated you
might end up with the big miss that
unbeautiful just a single day and I
think that's parallel some is hard
debugging barrel what is even harder so
so you sort of trying to push the limits
on the complexity of messages came all
over the world and then three different
types of colors I'm all trying to
compete in there just to the super you
just get a simple thing working first
give the sequential code working and
keep adding more and more story and I
make sure that each never equals the
problem colonel is because things are
non determinism some bugs that might
show up there might be hard crucial
design actually really matters another
thing I think especially for doing it
the most and stuff would be nice would
be to have a knob that basically you can
feel so i can say NOS p is everything in
writing PPE one is people's paleface
mechanic receive hopefully near 40 power
things seem utterly especially
he won't bug ya questions all right
we'll take a brief break and do the
quizzes in the meantime and for this
quiz there's one thing that you
mentioned so you have multiple course
you can write the one gigantic or
thousands phone calls and we didn't say
anything about performance of each pose
so one extreme assumption is no matter
what size of the culture one has the
same performance but that would be hard
that's because you can't make some kind
of assumption saying how the co size
relates to performance and then then
it's up to you I mean I mean these
things are there is no nice simple
equation things proportional to the area
versus whatever because a lot of things
going to that but you can make some
assumption anything day and it's just
just just fight one sentence say this is
my assumption this is how post
performance and then then then you can
put a man and do that and opposed to
come up with very complex nonlinear
sumption about cache sizes and stuff
like that credible path but you know her